are you recording by the way oh my hi
question I am BBQ time magazine's
Michael airing so what's the question
yeah what do you think the most exciting
innovation development over the next
decade that will help improve the state
of the world cure for cancer I like that
about you thanks babe oh we understand
that they're going to do whatever ya
Debbie mate is not what's nice oh it's a
little anything we've got youtube HD
memory yes I'm greedy and she's
threatening us were after youtube HD
it's got to be water purification that's
really good let's give you any anything
particularly you've seen that you think
you're really gonna make a difference so
I realized it'd be at my little question
nope it was a good answer something
what's filtration yeah I mean we've
already have those tubes where you know
I just feel like that's what we have
clean drinking water is through the very
unsettling with infrastructure you
something very exacting even but
credible importance to more corn by
property I could feed more people
goodnight a room work for me you should
you know yeah I wish I wish boy learn
more about should maybe grow their own
backyards but what how can you top the
one about this straw the water purified
I think she's gonna broke down your
straws well what about you I care for
cancer oh it was about one particular
than was really interesting have I seen
you talking when that was that was doing
something that I feel like that I think
some of the community companies here
starting to actually make an energy
cheaply without government see some look
but tech pioneers here where their drink
especially the solar so I talked to a
guy yeah the Russian go basis new
company e solar something like that is
some really interesting painting mirrors
making water I because I mean solar's
always been really expensive to produce
good there's this giant game zuma don't
remember which is unfortunate but is his
company basically co co so you put
something like that basically helps
finance street vendors post like an
affable fella resources in India
to buy solar panels and then use that to
Hawaii their their their car services
for their or their home but then inside
is a day they partner with local
financial institutions in order to sort
of to do them if you the one where do
you think what do you think ultimately
the innovation is going to come from I
mean you mentioned I mean it's going to
come out of places like provincial
capitals like Silicon Valley's you come
our places we don't expect to see
innovations like India sorry except the
love of it as a channel yesterday and to
have given student of the Carlile
purpose were talking about how you know
credit every Lancers how their location
let's talk about silicon Sally this and
that they're saying like not yeah you
gotta touches it to China India Mars
analogy alright cool thanks sure come by
again it's awesome what you're doing